I'm Alex Lyon and you're about to start
a seven part mini course in concise
clear and confident communication I put
this course together because I believe
it it's really the best first step for
you in your professional development and
laying that Foundation to develop strong
communication skills moving forward I
encourage you to watch all seven lessons
there's a little practice involved in
each one so you can actually hear and
then try the ideas out so let's jump
right into the first lesson
[Music]
in lesson one we're going after
long-windedness I encourage you to watch
this and go through it as many times as
you need to to make this material a
habit
tip one long-windedness is a key enemy
of good communication I'm always
surprised that really talkative people
assume that they're good communicators
but more talking does not equal good
communication in fact a lot of times if
these words Gabby chatty verbose and
talkative accurately describe you it's
probably forming a bad impression
especially in professional settings
Allison green said it like this you
might think well some people are
long-winded but it doesn't mean he
wouldn't do a good job the problem is
that a minimum it signals that you're
not good at picking up on conversational
cues and it raises doubts about your
ability to organize your thoughts and
convey needed information quickly
so strategy one resolve why you
sometimes talk too much when do you find
yourself multiplying words being overly
talkative is it just at work or is it in
social situations and what are you in
the moment thought processes that
trigger it are you insecure about
something what's going on in your mind
that's driving that over talkative
habits
because all the tips in the world will
not undo an unspoken belief that drives
that long-windedness
so excessive talkativeness is rooted in
our unspoken beliefs let's say you're a
physician and you're thinking to
yourself maybe you don't even realize it
but you're thinking I want people to
know I'm smart you will most certainly
talk too much to prove that and because
we live in a polite Society people just
play along but inside they're having an
entirely different thought process about
this conversation they will almost never
tell you directly that you're
long-winded however they will form
unfavorable impressions of you anyway
and so it's very important to realize
the impact in long-winded communication
can have on your professional
relationships and the people around you
so people long-winded for various
reasons what's your reason maybe there's
more than one is it insecurity maybe
some self-centeredness
do you want to show everything you know
like you're that physician do you like
the air time and the intention in other
words does it feel good when people are
listening to you and you love when
Everyone's Watching You In Action do you
mistake talking for adding value do you
mistake more talking for good
communication are there some control
issues going on in your heart and your
mind in other words do you like to steer
a conversation and be the one talking so
you dictate the pace and the flow of
things any one of these reasons and
there are many others could be driving
that long-windedness so it's really
important that you take some time and
get to the bottom of it strategy two is
to gauge your long-windedness rate
yourself on a scale of one to ten if
you're really concise give yourself a
one if you're somewhere in the middle
depending on situation five
if you're really long-winded a 10 and of
course you can give yourself other
scores but I would recommend setting a
goal to move at least below a five let's
say you want to be from a one to four
range depending upon the situation
because strategy number three is to
commit to conciseness as FDR said be
sincere be brief and be seated now he's
talking about presentations it sounds
like but I think this demonstrates his
commitment to conciseness because
conciseness really sets the stage for
that Clarity and that confidence that
we're all after and so commitment in
this sense means practicing the tips in
this video and in the next six lessons
and while you're doing it remember why
you want to be concise clear and
confident here are some reasons people
will pay attention to what you say when
you communicate this way people remember
what you say you'll have more impact
and you can lead more effectively so
there are lots of good reasons to do so
so long-windedness is a key enemy to
good communication some takeaway
strategies resolve why you sometimes
talk too much and then gauge your
long-windedness to help you set that
goal and then commit to practicing the
tips in this lesson and the remaining
six lessons so your first step is get to
the bottom of your unspoken reasons for
long-windedness that will really
catapult you through this course and
help you apply these tips with much more
Effectiveness looking forward we'll work
on how to form a concise overall message
concise sentences we'll work on
organizing your thoughts effective
pauses avoiding fillers and confident
non-verbals if you haven't yet
subscribed to this channel communication
coach I encourage you to do so and I
look forward to seeing you in the next
lesson